honorary Oscar to anyone hmm
[Music]
I would give an honorary Oscar to Ruth
Gordon the actress in Rosemary's Baby
the most phenomenal performer of her
generation Winona Ryder I love Winona as
a person and also she's been in so many
iconic films she means a lot to me
Angela Bassett has done some incredible
phenomenal work as an actor she's part
of the reason why I want to act I just
want her to have that moment an actress
who actually opened a lot of doors for
other black actresses in the UK and her
name is Carmen Monroe I just sort of
feel like I wouldn't be here if she
wasn't there a Drama teacher called
Hilary wood who trained actors at rad
and the leader Academy where I went to
feel very grateful to be one of her
pupils to my high school English teacher
a guy named Craig Hill I don't know if I
would have kept writing if it weren't
for him I'd give an honorary Oscar to
zelenski I'm not going to beat that what
a hero and he's an actor there's a
humanitarian award yeah so that's him
zielinski honestly my wife how could I
tell her how much I appreciate her I
would think of someone who's been
working for a long time I would have
given an Oscar to my parents I'm just
keeping a hundred I give it to my mom my
brother Edmund and I who started in this
game when we were both three years old
and Mom is the one who pushed it if ever
there is a day that I ever receive you
know an Oscar I would definitely
dedicate and actually give that to her
because she deserves it the most I would
give an honorary Oscar to John Waters
that's a really good answer he really
deserves one for her future work which I
have no doubt will be incredible Sarah
Paulie maybe she'll get an Oscars
Sean for everything she's done for
American film and New York Film and
queer film David Fincher Michael Mann
because their iconic American filmmakers
who have completely set the tone of
amazing movies if I could give an
honorary Oscar to someone it would be to
David Lynch
first film
first woman
I always feel that ozu deserves an
honorary Oscar because his films are so
beautiful and elegant and so different
from Western Cinema Athol full garage
the Great South African playwright who
also many of his plays were made into
very great films some of which he
directed himself Apple Fugard he's just
this complete underrated brilliant Tony
award-winning Telluride celebrated
living artists and I think it's his time
if I could give an honorary Oscar I
would give it to the crew there are a
lot of people who were there before we
get to work and who stay there after we
get to work and we make it possible for
us to do the very best work that we are
capable of doing I wish we had more
opportunities to thank the crew I
personally would give an honorary Oscar
to all the public who are returning
postcovid to movie theaters and making
movie theaters the experience we all
want them to be so that's millions of
oscars but I think every one of them
deserves it
[Music]
thank you